on parle de juridique en fait il faut
acter une séparation politique est ce
que c'est la solution est désormais il
faut acter vous pourrez prendre deux
minutes c'est pas un drame
une séparation politique on le vit dans
d'autres choses mais vous savez en
politique seuls les actes comptent
gérald arbanats par exemple s'est
présenté sur une liste de la république
en marche contre la liste centriste aux
sénatoriales liste aei la liste des
républicains le premier ministre que
j'aime bien avec qui je me suis
entretenu cette après midi il soutenait
le candidat quelques concurrents dans
les yvelines
alors ma position quand les choses vont
dans le bon sens sa voix parce qu'on les
soutienne l'exclusion si c'est la
solution juridique mais en fait c'est
acté une séparation comme je considère
que monsieur bilan pour des raisons sans
doute encore plus grave parce qu'elles
touchent à des valeurs fondamentales
c'est totalement séparée de notre
famille politique puis je voudrais dire
un mot parce qu on a beaucoup parlé de
laurent wauquiez des élections à
l'intérieur de l air et puis on a parlé
du nouveau monde
je vois que tous les cas le vieux monde
est revenu bien vite ce qu'un scanner et
auto désigné par le président de la
république
on va mettre nos mais les trente membres
qui vont l'entourer
c'est quand même une conception du
nouveau monde qui m'étonne un peu je
préfère les processus plus démocratique
à l'intérieur des formations politiques